happy Monday we're starting the week off
right with a little bit of overwatch for
Xbox one if you're on Xbox one straight
at us blurts on the old gamertag be lui
a ERT I bet they'll put it in the chat
it's nice to see everyone
hey John G clueless gamer yes vote
anonymous a a John an what's up captain
quasar Jace good to see you among kt9
but yeah we're playing some overwatch
and I'm gonna start by playing my boy
Bastion today I've got on a Nick Cage
t-shirt and it's creepy because people
will look at me and then they'll do a
double take because it freaks them out
it's it's a subtle Nic Cage yeah a
subtle Nic Cage if you saw my Instagram
we did a little mister Granma days we're
trying to get sponsored by Lacroix Sola
croaks the Crocs or whatever if you're
watching please sponsor us we did a fun
Instagram where we had Nick Cage
drinking Lacroix
oh ho somebody's laughing at Bastion
wise Bastion a bad guy did pick he's got
big guns right hey Petros
I tried to set up a game with Finn's but
couldn't figure it out / no one was
playing overwatch so you guys are
ridiculous and so dead yep yep I got hit
in the back you bastard hey what's up M
D and M diesel caca far why is it were
laughing at Labatt Bastion its fashion a
terrible character he hates the fans
confirmed captain quasar I donate the
fans at all Oh after this game Omega cos
the game I did a custom game where but
it said no player know what no one of my
friends that's you guys are playing this
game no friends yep
someone said I'm on now
oh yeah light him up light him up light
him up light him up
gotta stay mobile you know he's terrible
when not on defense oh well we'll see
about that that he makes terrible noises
oh he does I like the noise of the the
constant machine gun I think that's a
pretty good noise to make I'm gonna go
I'm gonna get some I'm gonna go up top
here I'm gonna get a little get a little
up top love and then rain death down
upon my opponents high that's what they
used to call me in prison death rain
uh-oh what were you a tax evasion what's
that my calling white collar yeah
there's a lot of white collar hey hey
what's up hey come here hey whoops wrong
thing sorry
wow that sucked maybe Bashi does suck
you know I'm gonna change my hero guys
let's change our hero let's change our
hero - how about a little tracer right
everybody loves tracers but that's the
big thing a little shade here we go oh I
don't quite understand how tracers time
stuff works like it only goes back for
me and not for everybody else like how
does that I don't understand she's she's
playing you can't play with the temporal
time flow you know what I'm saying it's
a great kitchen we secured it yeah
screen comm SK REE any D comm I think
well the big thing hey the literal
penguin hey penguin if you're the
literal penguin how are you typing
I guess voice chat can work big booties
Alexander leavin
gelati oh do I ever get offended mokona
insults me no he pays me so I say thank
you sir for your insults I duly
appreciate it I had a little Instagram
cutter that I did a YouTube stream for
III and I was like hey man you want to
be in this Instagram he's like is it for
the show it's like no he's like all
right I'll be in it okay and then he
made a face and then he just goes put my
boss is obviously very fond of me in
there and I was like okay he told me
what to do so he made me crap he made me
[ __ ] on myself basically which I thought
was a new level of messed up in this
I'll put a link in put a Lincoln well
I'm just owning this guy dead I fell off
no go up Dimmie
oh wait can every white oh I didn't
rewind time that was dumb there is no
III segment but Conan dude let's go wait
what's happening all the kill cams
myself when you kill yourself that sucks
wait how do I turn back time again what
is it oh that's what it is all right
let's try that again Guvna
why my movies so slow Oh cuz I'm
crouched for some reason there we go
that but that the tracer is most like
how I think which is crazy I'm a crazy
person who thinks in a crazy way oh boy
I love killing gunslingers yeah I mean
this is Elios this is a Greek island
play a little bit of this with oh by the
way Game of Thrones guys we played this
we played overwatch there was the last
clueless gamer with Peter Dinklage and
Lena Headey from Game of Thrones
let the Game of Thrones spoilers begin
thank you
boom-boom-boom dead dead dead dead
killer killer killer got her right in
the back that's how I like to do it
screw honor man people are wondering why
you don't stream on your own stream
because a I've been writing a book and a
movie in a TV show so it's very very
busy and I'm a drunk and I drink a lot
of tequila which I Bali should be doing
while streaming actually so we'll get
back into it whoa
my man oh my god I would get murdered on
the keyboard situation obviously well
that sucked I'm doing pretty good trace
without John Snow King in the north
I think we're changing our character
again who should we be let's be uh not
torben bourbon let's be I like a good
soldier 76 as much as the next guy Don
Julio silver you know frame rate you
know what's up but we'll get back into
the drunky drunk streams at some point
who says I'm not drunk now by the way
drinking at work best thing ever
I'm drunk on what am I drunk on Lacroix
the best sparkling water out there we
won that's right that's right a crock we
if anyone from how do you say it across
I think like raw the Kroy Kroy Kroy if
you're watching I don't like it's
delicious
Andy truce oh that's a good that's a
good move while she blew him up pretty
good minutes all right now we're gonna
try to cuz we're going to try to do open
my loop box
I'm leaving the game let's try kids now
if you guys are I'm gonna see if
anybody's out there watch what watch
what happens when I see if anyone's out
there hey hatchet man cam alright guess
what you're in hatchet man cam you're
invited
now it's me versus hatchet man cam
basically I think we should add AI right
make it crazy sex
there's only me versus hatchet man camp
all right one on one hatchet man camp
let's do it you guys if you want to play
get in here no players available all
right fair enough
[Music]
I'm changing sorry uh I'm editing pot ah
ah
can I change but can i but with the
thing can i okay fair enough
we're doing it how do I start oh for
God's sake
Oh for Jesus the love of Pete for pete's
sake can I just please it's his new game
called can I select start I've had too
much coffee there we go let's do it
you're mine hatchet man can saw Eastern
Promises last night when he goes like oh
dude Easter pups this is great future
promises is great back me up chat play
ps4 at Fred Flores I didn't I don't have
a copy than the ps4 is upstairs we
decided go xbox you play a lot of ps4
here I'm switching it up I may need you
all right Farrah I'm gonna kill you with
Reaper I'm coming in hot hatchet man cam
hey shady this is Xbox I'm gonna bury
the hatchet yeah rebuy rebuy nature
Lulla fun my dad always says for Pete's
sakes I am your dad this is how you find
out sorry you had to find out of the
child like this for Pete sakes
who's the Pete they're talking about and
why are we doing something for his sake
oh boy Reapers just always sits the
light-hearted guy st. Peter
Oh sing Connor like for God's sake Peter
is for like pity instead of Oh for
pity's sake for pity for Simon Peters
sake can we play with it yeah JD dose ya
m89 what do you mean ad me I tried add
you add us you add us bro harder daddy
el Grande a vp when I say overwatch you
say PC overwatch not playing a PC
although the steam controlers I do dig
pretty highly well hatchet man cam so
far I think I'm winning
oh no wait we haven't started what's
good Kate what's gonna happen in the
cage no one knows there we go let's do
it I'm defending it bring your a-game
hacci I have to sell me memes oh I'll
get memes all day long
Jesus Christ art right oh this is how
I'm gonna get murdered now hatchet who
are you playing let's go let's go
I'm not offline y'all no defendant
defendant get in there defend hotle
where do i I wish I could run faster I'm
not gonna get that time stop the payload
whoa I'm getting destroyed I feel like
I'm just gonna get murdered a lot in
this game but you know what that's okay
let's go for a little yeah yeah let's go
for some Winston I like a good monkey
man Toby pickles I'm not sure what Conan
is right now I think [ __ ] about Jonathan
troll I'm not sure keemstar is dockings
is God who are got a lightning gun all
right well I'm getting just completely
destroyed in this game hatchet man cam
you're killing me maybe I'm appearing
offline maybe I should change maybe I
should change it should I pause this to
change it like people will add you but
then you have to oh I have to like
accept their thing all right after this
game we're gonna go and accept a bunch
of people
tell me that's wrong here we go let's
get on it
damnit Oh Hatchin man can that was a
personal kill nice job
let's get back in let's go let's go who
should I be who's the best you figured I
would be Winston Thank You sunyata doing
your job
damnit
ah this is just this is just
disappointing it's nature's call a
disappointment cam alright alright I'm
gonna add a bunch of people back give me
a second time let me just have hatchet
man cam just finish killing my ass here
it comes it's coming in here guys I need
your help we can't hatchet man cam
oh I killed some folks though I think I
got the cut through there pretty easy
I wish anyone any of the AI for my team
could kill a single dude they're totally
not helping
damn it's gotta stop this payload you
guys
Jesus Christ
Oh hatchet man can
he's a dick that likes to take credit
away from the other scientists we
talking [ __ ] about Winston's
that just that just hurts my feelings
look I sounded like a 13 year old that
just hurts my feelings
kill em Jesus God please oh my god
somebody freaking just come here just
come here that's right god damn it I'm
going to eat yeah take that who else
wants some of this lightning good take
that hatchet make no floating stupid
monk
whew I did kill a lot of people though
you have to give it up there's no way
we're gonna stop this pelo from going in
there I'm sorry to be such a negative
Nelly guys Palin's going in I have a bad
feeling
kill his ass Jesus somebody just kill
this dude
nice job hatchet man can your schooling
me get school no way we could stop this
payload young changing dudes I know that
I know Evers gonna laugh at me if I'm go
back to Bastion
time for some turning let's go setting
up the turret
[Music]
experience tranquility
[Music]
into the onerous
welcome back welcome back welcome back
let's go welcome back we got this baby
welcome back
[Music]
yup yup
what now what now who wants to talk [ __ ]
about Bastian oh that's right bring this
payload back out of here come on hey you
got to pull your weight now let's go
let's go that's right
pull it on back pull oh god it's moving
so slow backwards
no [ __ ]
nice job hatchet man gotta come back I
got to come back come on come on we got
this we got this
death spectating let's go it's right on
the precipice you guys we could do this
I'm gonna turn into a tank murder these
fools
get my boy on top let's set it up but
set it up
set it up move it back we're right on
the edge we got this
defense guys defense let's go bring it
back yeah fire those grenades one-legged
dude
[Music]
bring the hey what happened
Oh sniper stop come on man
Oh minute thirteen we got to stop them
we're so close Oh someone's asking for
moderation find you guys on snapchat
there you go thank you for adding us no
god damn it no oh [ __ ] oh they're really
making a push at the end here I think
that's it come on Reaper a stop of a
javelin stop
[Music]
we got this pull it back
No
[Music]
yes I think we did it here you stop the
payload over time oh come on pull it out
Wow hands up for Bastian whoever [ __ ] on
Bastian look at this play the game my
boy good game hatchet man this is what
this is I was just their ego just owning
there we go yep it's just a chainsaw
doom you know whew that was you know
what I'm going to hatch a man I'm vote
for you great game hatchet man hatchet
man came good job okay
now Beth is gonna talk while I add
people what do we think about that guys
who has questions how do i where's mine
I don't know anything about comic-con
yet I had the back is this um what
happens oh my god I have to do each one
of these this is gonna be the worst
that's fine I'm just gonna wow this is
gonna be awful we'll do a couple people
though then we're gonna see who's online
then we're gonna do it here's question
how does it go and keep his hair so firm
you know what's interesting
yeah if you ever meet Conan one thing
you could say he does his own hair for
the most part so and that's something
that he he he takes private so if you
say oh man your hair looks great
he'll be like oh thank you very much I
mean if you say anything to him he'll be
like thank you very much cuz he's a nice
guy and he likes many people but that is
something that he actually really likes
is yes people yeah exactly people
commenting on his hair because he he
kind of does it himself there did we
match our clothes to fit the room weird
like color palette that we have
everything man experimenting with
fashions you know we've got a
interesting we like you know this is a
good this is a visual medium yeah this
is a visual medium yeah in that way
whoops whoops whoops oh god oh god okay
I'm gonna add two more people and then
we're gonna get into it
nope not all settings thank you where we
going hello
that's Brent bench presses 278 pounds
that's true I can do that and I know
what that means
that's that is what I do every day
Marvel's spider-man my favorite kind of
pizza I'll answer this I don't know if
it's for me but I've been at Pizza two
years so yeah it is not thin crust cuz
that stuff is what no no olives but they
have to be brick oven baked olives black
olives brick oven bit what why because
if you put them in a regular life you
know a pretentious you sound right now I
mean I'm talking about like add / -
cheese not like a nice place
Oh whatever - cheese pizza I've never
heard of / - I know Domino's I know
Pizza Hut Papa Gino's Domino's thin
crust in Domino's thick crust are - my
favorite pizzas because I grew up on
it's like eating like I'm not yet I know
that's why I like it it's delicious
okay we've done a lot of people here all
right let's see here now we're gonna
play we're gonna play a custom game
we're gonna add people perfect hatchet
man came the only one Mac we still don't
have any friends we still have no
friends how is that possible how you
dicks how does this happen
Joe the non troll what are you talking
about Lord of the gnomes man yeah it's
oh wait a second wait we got somebody in
there we got somebody in email kt9 we're
in who else can we add there's no one
else who else can join can people join
our games do I add it and invite asking
too much of you
hatchet man cam my boy or girl
in there invite to custom game anybody
how else do we no one else is is it no
one else is in don't see anybody else in
there alright
just us three I guess how about you two
against me let's do this well you joined
soccer mommy get in here
snake eyes t-shirt no turn dot it's uh
we got Nicolas Cage today can you see
it's a little Nic Cage murder everybody
not the bees not the bees Oh God not the
bees I love people tuning in just now
like like what is wrong with you no
players available you guys are looking
at this see there you go
alright I guess it's just us kids I kind
of want to ban Joe the non troll he's
super annoying dude stop with the kiemce
talk it's it's super annoying scale one
to ten how much do I like Conan ten baby
this guy weird I am super weird
don't go crazy I got Nick caged
that's right join the rage cage no
players available I don't know what to
do let's get back at him let's get back
in a more fighting
shall we let's add some AI shadowy
difficulty medium yeah difficulty medium
seems good alright let's do a fiver
Rooskies I've got four out four is
pretty fun hmm I know don't I can I
change my player how do i I'm not a huge
fan of oh wait a second where are these
people come hey what the hell Oh guys
you're shot yeah they might have just
showed up we're gonna make some friends
now I don't know how that happened
oh yeah now they're in alright let's add
some people yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah let's do it yeah except
I'm swapping you on the other team there
pal
you're going into this team and then
we'll put a pot on this team oh wait is
it healthy mush your Marty in here boom
look at this Stan oh now we're in kids
now we're in let's do it whoo I love it
now all right guys this is it
superhot VR read by nature I did hear
about superhot VR I'm very excited all
right who are we picking who are you
picking we still got two empty slots
guys you gotta join up Reinhardt's low
team damage okay fine what about you
defense heroes are you guys picking got
a bastion we got a I'll start with maybe
Reaper is that Alright I'll start with a
reaper there we go
who else who were waiting to join
hopefully bill
all right here we go yeah let's go guys
thanks did you just think thanks here we
go
it should be a thing somebody's saying
something we go I do like this old hover
cap I think it's got the old-school body
but then it's like a hover hover 'sons
situation ooh I
yeah Goku you can join all right here we
go
here we go stay sharp y'all stay sharp
great greetings hello how do I say
greetings back I'm gonna say
what did I say I feel like Reaper
doesn't know how to hit on girls very
well he's like I like death it's like
dude it's a first date chill out you
know just say something nice about a
movie alright here we go let's get in
let's get in get behind your boy get
behind your boy that was a mistake
Oh who shot me the back I did kill
somebody though who was that who is this
oh it was a fair I think come on guys
let's just try not to all get killed at
once I think that's a key oh I love from
Canadia well thank you little penguin
there we go let's get into it
sure oh Jesus
I'm getting just destroyed by whoever
that is
Oh hatchet man can my enemy man you know
what I feel I hate the sin let's go time
to hop around Hey congratulate Rieke how
old were you try a hole did you turn oh
no it's this one again ass oh here's a
fact all the cars and overwatch our
hover cars because this game was built
on the scraps of a failed blizzard MMO
that had a standard rule that no hover
cars were allowed so the over art design
team put them in out of spite so
passive-aggressive I love it
oh oh oh get a girl the rocket hammer
why don't you alright F tracer I'm going
back to let's go to your boy Hans oh I
see what's going on she lyric flies we
accomplished our tire good Myung mind it
boy I'm good
[ __ ] ah you guys come on
this is bad
nice attire guys
oh great I'm not holding up my end of
the deal either arrow and plain tracer
to hold this you owe to hold it oh
that's good to know
yes I'm going back to what I know I'm
sorry
hey ray 269 what's up nope well we lost
sorry my fault
but I'm a poor loser it's like good job
guys
I want a rematch awkward style doc
resident three patchy man cam ooh
well done probably cuz you hit tracer in
the head with your giant ham yeah that's
what it was actually hot damn son you're
a Monet that's what they say right
you're a Monet thank you
dingy hard counters fashion Oh easy to
come on PC there we go that's what I get
from playing bastions it got so much
hate for Bastion he's just a robot who
loves Birds guys what's the deal the
fellow is called Starcraft ghost was in
development for years they eventually
scrapped it for some reasons wow that's
crazy
damn everyone just picks Bastion at PC
fair enough Oh
choose from Argentina Thank You
Frederico I'm really sorry about Messi
by the way Messi quit the Argentinian
national team which sucks I'm gonna use
let's see someone I haven't used yet you
check right out look Joe uh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh we're on Xbox one today I mean I did
that to hide myself you know why don't
you change that real quick how do I
change that here my profile oh this is
gonna be good I'm starting a game and
I've literally taken it off did I screw
everyone I don't know
oh yeah it does say a peer offline
online there we go
guys I fixed it here we out here I fixed
it and now we're back
Hey good to see you hello sergeant fat
John a healthy health healthy mushroom
it's good hey why did everyone invite
the mushroom to the party cuz he was a
fun guy get it
fungi that's for you healthy mushroom
that sucks for you no it's not the joke
the joke is it's playing Words you
screwed me because I put money on that
game don't ever bet on me just like
Messi quit out of it that's crazy mess
he's still gonna dominate Club play guys
so don't think that he's done never
wanna say that we stand by the way he's
gonna come back for the World Cup don't
think he just I think it messy just
basically rage quit okay now we meet
ourselves online listen no we didn't cuz
we're still playing with people wow that
was a absolute beating
let's go what am i let's see I got the
concussion mine
steel trap Jesus Christ hatchet man camp
came in hard you got a mention and B
that's right
timid timtockery still about fair I'm
wolf so this game is too expensive it's
expensive its spending brainpower that I
don't
kill somebody Jesus awkward childless
job hard to hit that robot ninja man so
when she's jumping around
well like who's the who's who's healthy
ninja I killed one person that's pretty
good you got oh God
follow the dragon y'all just death
way to go whoever that was nice job
oh I got him at the trap though haha
healthy mushroom is she's laying down
some law you get a concussion might have
dropped and jump really high there we go
watch this come on damn it I got brought
back though thanks sergeant fat John I
think you wasted on me we got to get in
there man they set up a turret in the in
the thing that's fine how-do-you-do
governor oh Jesus
stun
[Music]
getting rail I don't think this guy's
all that good things might have messy
magic which I change heroes I'm gonna
stick with chuck rat for a while Swedish
I stick with junk rat what do you guys
think
junk rat is killing couple dudes
oh here we go
dammit all resurrected here we go thank
you
alright here we go doing it like you
said
oh yeah ah that was awesome
I just shoot random loot this dude
you got to get in there y'all they're
doing a good job of keeping us away damn
this job here we go
get back in there come on sergeant fat
John how do we get in there oh my god
I'm just too slow I think what about
Lucy Oh
[Music]
damn it's nice job guys you change to
refer you to teleport intellect oh I
should I should change the Reaper
teleporting it well done guys well done
like dark resins just soon there
who's the play
a child was just killing with it this is
just now how do we add more people come
you have more people joke right is very
little health well done
can we show lobby not social Thank You
shimmer that Lobby can you have more
Pete ball nope
Oh somebody jumped out what whoops
whoops but something's happening no
players available guys who wants to come
in to reinvent them
[Music]
I invited you guys though y'all sitting
playing overwatch I might I mean you
know no one's
[Music]
I mean these people are coming gonna
jump out real quick pause that thoughts
no we're gonna plant a couple these
folks you want to come on in
sure yes you can see my real name my
gamertag is Blair so that's basically my
real name my first name is Erin this is
extremely onerous everybody how are we
doing today I think we're good
we have nice Seltzer's alright two more
people then we go back in Kaunas my hero
we're not very friends it wasn't I love
your profile pic my oh yeah it's pretty
good likeness that's my face yeah
alright let's go we're back in now can i
a players available might take a second
I'm gonna fill this one with an AI right
so we're not we're not one down is
everyone okay with that hero nope just
team one thank you
who should we pick I do like a good ah
selector 76 all right no one else is on
here yo let's go up and see if we can
actually see if we see anybody else it's
you no one else out here nobody there's
nobody there
all right let's go rob revenge uh yeah
I'll add you next time well we'll play a
game and then add people
Valene schemer so what do you guys do
over there just interested in what your
day-to-day job is well we're getting
ready for our week of shows at Comic Con
which is a lot of stuff we're getting a
really good time there's gonna be a lot
of good stuff this is true what else is
going on well we're putting together the
team podcast a team cocoa podcast which
hopefully the first episode will be
viewed yep we started a new franchise
kill the backlot music series with did
Dawes because we have such a cool back
lot here it's the W that Warner Brothers
back glad they shot a Hail Caesar they
shot a ton of great stuff here
pee-wee's big adventure amazing saddles
lot of stuff so we a spider-man all this
other stuff so we shot some bands
playing in the back lot so every band we
shoot we shoot in the cool location here
that you don't normally see which is
really cool we started that
what else does sound like on there's so
much happening this week there's more
comic-con news coming this week also
just the day-to-day of we're doing a
show today what's that poison bomb
please robot
I've never sneezed on camera that's
definite not right definitely use that
camera enjoy that poison bomb no phones
alright I'm liking Widowmaker here I
think I'm lucky I'm liking me some
Widowmaker guys poison bomb that poison
Bob that poison bomb shove something up
my nose to force a sneeze while we have
a lot of sneeze fetishists yeah kind of
like show us your feet in yeah weird
I mean I don't have to sneeze right now
although I do have terrible allergies
that's why my nose is so red Wow
that was awful this coated still beat me
yes silence daylian Conan still beats me
all the time porn is not a gamer kind of
Coco bot people are saying he's still on
offline stance what are you talking
about guys I'm not an offline status I
won't stand for this these lies I made
it so let's see I don't know what to
think of like you're turning the lights
oh you know what oh I see a pier online
great you know I'm appearing online
alright everybody I don't know what
nobody knows nobody does maybe it didn't
say that before what even what even
happened
do-do-do-do-do-do-do I don't like this
board me I'm not saying that sport
because it takes too long to get to the
action
cheap I take that back I think that adds
a whole bunch of stuff comes flying out
many gamers
Oh God one second getting murdered hold
please
damnit I literally can't even
but avatar looks like a discount priest
version of Guy Fieri asus4 bar dish
Wow cool that's pretty cool Guy Fieri
get on the point yeah exactly Triple D
Triple D my friend L shoot men's
favourite engage a favorite show yes
join the next few small buddies
yes try the next game please what please
play with us capture the objective guys
we can do this
[Music]
take a breather
gotta kill that big robot you guys shot
the more damage get on the freakin point
Joe
just do the poison moms stay around
after I die hope so
tracer oh right in the head
wowthat's up
yeah
then we would go back to Reaper I think
right I've killed some people with this
girl though what do you guys say I mean
I feel like it might still be a good
idea to stay up on the
[Music]
tracer it is a visit tracer I'm now
tracer
Oh
get it get it
contestant we're contesting oh [ __ ] oh
come on guys come on let's get over
there let's get over there come on come
on we got this da you're so close
I blame myself I could have just held
out for one more second good job guys
man that's three zero you killed us
I'll hold the trigger as alien town says
awkward child is just murdering oh
that's me
look at that oh my god awkward child
guitar lever says just farm kills
I got to go awkward child man I'm child
killing the game never you get hurt
while playing is crazy
carbine you go back in time to full oh
that's right I keep forgetting it
alright let's go see if we can add some
more people we have more people is that
possible
BAM
huh what happened how's that true love
it let's take this out and then get this
other person hold on oh please bad wolf
bro
bad wolf get your ass in here bad wolf
bad wolf bad wolf here boy
all right one more chance that we're
starting without you yeah good job bad
wolf good wolf good wolf all right let's
go let's go
well you the clowns you move around like
sticks you slow that's right dine so
much thank you I'm trying to move it
faster is that can I have that one over
there is that Lacroix La Crosse it's
delicious
[Music]
delicious and nutritious
there's no nutrition but there is water
which is good we're getting oxygen and
hydrogen for the day um all right let's
play someone who haven't played a while
yeah that's my little Lucy oh you know
yeah boy
oh yeah he's cool b-boy status please
their Orlan the rollerblades Beth sorry
primera Singh rollerskates mall not
responder I wish this was fun
Oh Oh I swallowed a lot of gas or then
Oh
coming back with Boyd's coming back
Challenger 78 we like you too thank you
for joining no wait
how do I change all right now I'm
healing everybody all right guys all
right this guy cuz he shoots his bet he
shoots his jams at people he's basically
like he's just got something that shoots
Spotify playlist musica you can either
make people faster you can heal people
so I made everybody real fast
come on guys let's go come on we can't
lose again it's 3-0
oh they got their own lucio I'm
switching it up I'm healing everybody
let's break it down try to heal
everybody
Oh got killed by the gunslinger oh damn
he lit up everybody heal him up heal him
up get him up get him up
all right Reinhard let's go move forward
boy
speed him up speed him up speed him up
I killed the other Lucio
capture that point my friends heal him
up pull him up pull him up got it Oh No
that was bad what just happened a lot of
points at the moment you got a boy over
here behind the little statue yeah heal
him up get him up get him up dead
we're lasting a lot longer though I feel
like I'm doing so good
guys maybe I'm just a healer maybe I you
know what I'm saying it's like that time
I bon jovi lay your hands on me like
when you played dodgeball and there's a
medic nope that's that's not like
is it better - oh God is it better to be
fast or be Healy right now
or be bleeding Oh God
that's a turret Danny I'm not going that
way
attack attack attack
Jesus Christ
fili Kili alright Healey it is ah you're
over here Reinhard bro chill up dude
get away from me going this way
Celie it is I don't know what just
happened
well objective fail we just lost Oh
[Music]
somebody saying he lap points and speed
toward the points that's good advice
thank you
turn on and hedge flow hello I'm gonna
do some emoting guys yeah what's up
doing some boating thank alright let's
go
alright speed to the point everybody I
got my rollerblades on let's go speed to
the point speed to the point his feet -
speed to the speed to the point it's
beating to the point speeding to the
points beets beets beets beets ready to
moyen speeding to the point alright now
he'll at the point he'll at the point
he'll he'll deal at the point I'm dying
I'm dying I'm dying I'm dying I'm dying
I'm dying I'm behind this dude
alright well got killed the point is our
home are you afraid of your home tell
you speed boosts to get away all right
I'm gonna be good at this right as this
as you appreciate his sweet jams attack
let's go speed to the point
can't catch me
ah yeah I guess you can't catch me
actually very easily I have a good
musculature in my legs I don't know if
those are robotic legs or not but I
looks like I've really worked out not a
fan of this mat my favourite map might
be Ilyas actually it's just so pretty
yeah well live there I want to live
inside the girl yes Mac let's go
he'll about heal him up
heal them up doing my part
skate in I skate around I skate out
Jesus Christ that was I skate out of
life and die immediately
Kings rose beautiful I agree how'd you
buy wool Shady I'm Chitti where I can't
believe we're not friends
oh and you next time you get in here sup
sup sup hey what's up I can't see the
thing hey move the chat over the
leverage it hey what if I can sir what's
up oh wow that's bad let's attack let's
go guys let's get in there time to
attack oh they got a frickin turret in
there come on guys we gotta take those
guys out
jaesi doesn't want to guess this
something that isn't funny I'm sure
you're talking about counterpoise are
yeah turbans chart chart is blocking
your path no [ __ ] look for another way
contesting it I'm Kaz I was trying to
contest I don't think this is gonna go
well for us nope ah 5-0 guys was ever on
my team I'm really sorry I feel like I'm
letting everybody down I am the only
common denominator of having lost every
single game Oh sort let's see their
day's McCree I like that blue yeah
damn damn foods they feel like 60 people
damn dude oh my god but boil it crazy
gotta give it up to swear down line tie
new menu runs as a lie I'm letting
everybody down basically that's my
that's what I do guys I let everybody
down
who's the show tonight I'll be the
lovely and beautiful Aubrey Plaza will
be on the show tonight as well as who's
that fan they were great to bail I'll
pierce the veil it's awesome and it's
already very excited about it yeah
Perceval so dope frank grillo where's
Frank Grillo for how will people know
Frank Moore oh really
oh yeah he's crossbones yeah he's
awesome brother he was also in the purge
to Kingdom two which is that new show
they're like oh yeah watch Kingdom man
yeah Frank Grillo that's awesome he was
in the purge yeah he's great
he was a guy who in Captain America the
second one fights Captain America in the
elevator mmm he's pretty good defenses
we go the first ones good I mean I the
idea is fun the new one it's super
interesting cuz it's like Tropic like
yeah Erica purging again really whatever
it's like a lot of Trump overtones and
you're gonna be sorry you said that when
the chat blows up a try to trump this I
take it back that's right go back in
time Frank Crowe is coming out in the
new purge oh he's gonna be in the new
one - yeah
whoa I like it dude Frank hello
look he's he seems like a really nice
dude
all systems shakes out come back oh yeah
we gotta Lucy on our teams they just
felt the speed up it's my cousin Blas
jump-jet so this is the payload right oh
this is what's his faces all right guys
quiet - quiet time for the purge what
would you do if there's a real purge
would you go out and perjured you try to
stay in and defend
I think most people just like go on
vacation yeah I would just like it just
taste like in the it's just the United
States yeah go to Canada do I want to be
in the objective I think I want to be
like up there right they come
[Music]
killed somebody felt pretty good oh yeah
oh yeah sergeant fat John making a sweet
little turret over there a sweet little
turret yeah I can see him coming they're
coming from this side I wonder
bring it on y'all I think we got it
what contested
Oh what we gotta kill count no where's
the kill count
I'm digging fair right now though stick
with Farah that's good
yeah the concussive blast I love seeing
like crazy like crossfire
mr. McMahon concussive blast so thank
you for that advice that I totally did
not use
let's get back in man Thank You sergeant
grats little thing there this actually
is a beautiful location too bad we have
to looks like shoot a bunch of stuff
Burbank
I know I def idea ladies horror movie
got him
thank you fun
to test him what tested my ass
oh the barrage oh that sucks I should
have done the barrage from up top I'll
hold the jump button there we go four to
four seconds come on guys we can do this
is this gonna be our first victory
this doesn't look good whatever about
that oh nice smasheroo there I hate
keyboard mouse sorry I know Kevin I
tried to play some Reinhardt
no no no guys we can't lose in this last
ten seconds come on
[Music]
no not over time no we can't lose now
Jesus and we gonna lose because of me
again
guys can you can't let this happen
let's go let's go oh I just I need to be
more careful about running into danger I
think this sucks
great I got murdered out of the air by
awkward child oh I will say basically
yeah stay off the ground with Pharaohs
Clark I got signed out of twitch o-o
back in action you're doing time to
change guys that always works for me
right let's do a little Reaper walks
what's doing well with three before I
need to get it get up-close what are
Reapers things again rate his lb shadow
step
well this looks terrible up here
finally I killed one person you guys
nope back that payload up thank you
No
Wow the soldier fits Brendan seven be
fired playing soldier 76 you think so I
was getting just destroyed with soldier
76 mi defending the payload no I'm
supposed to stop it right oh Jesus
Christ
oh my god stand behind the payload right
now
[Applause]
well that didn't work out there am I am
I am I trying to kill the payload or am
I trying to stop you guys I'm sorry I'm
letting everybody down but this is
that's my way there we go I got the
death blossom
thank you for sergeant fat John for the
armor yeah read my nature I'm not sure
what is the story to this game
cool got murdered that was cool
wow there's a lot of fighting happening
let's go I do have my death blossom
loaded up and ready to go so maybe
that'll do something no but is that good
or bad it's bad right this is good we're
here and this is happening we're moving
to back now right
guilt I killed some guys I killed a
couple folks dance down sad first about
throwing and I'm actually trying wait
somebody said I should be not gonna
matter now but let's try it
[Applause]
[Music]
all right this is where I always screw
it up let's try to not screw it up
did we do it yes at last we did it Oh
guys there we go all right one more game
then we're gonna call it I think healthy
mushroom wait
damn then came out just murdered 60
people I gotta like like junk rat is
kind of fun so as your fat John gave me
a lot of gave me a lot of armor that's
right no healer blade watch oh it's
magic love the cars funny story I used
to take when I took a sketch writing
class from Heon Roberts from UCB back in
New York every week after the sketch
writing class I would go my friend Tony
I would go to McDonald's in Union Square
and every week the class is six or eight
weeks long we ran into ric ocasek from
the cars at mcdonald's every single week
and you know i'm huge and i have gray
hair still like by the third week and
he's really tall it'll be because he
looks like ric ocasek is he's refusing
so every like by the third week we'd be
like hey hey what's that like how's it
going and then and then like two months
later he was on the show and then the
cars on the show I know he was on the
show for something he might have been
again zoo album and the green oh there
we go from Weezer and I think he might
have actually good guest on the show and
and I was downstairs and he walks by me
and he just goes I know is my friend Ric
Ocasek that I saw from McDonald's it was
so weird every single week I saw it so
funny
are we just breaking stuff in here can I
get my little bomb and get it in the
definitely the coolest gun in the game
John card I think we can all agree
healing Lindner cuz the Wi-Fi said
freeze at 24 here right and I was also
the cheapest ATM in all George was like
99 cents yeah and it's funny right near
I think this is still true in Union
Square there's this restaurant called
the coffee shop and it's just full of
supermodels everybody works there is a
model male and female because upstairs
is a modeling casting agency they all
work there to try to get discovered
which is just so funny if you want to
see some good-looking people totally
copy
oh hey jug brat well there's the death
and I ricochet some these off-the-wall
I hit a couple
predict O'Shea oh yeah
Kenji awkward whatever is just killing
me
absolutely I make this like gun from a
paintball gun in a car awesomely it's
got a weird steer shift on it also these
guns are just so heavy everybody's
forums must be really uh very developed
forearms in these high spin the piss out
of those grenades to somebody
just raining death down on these a-holes
yeah we're in
[Music]
Oh what was that oh damn I think Mike
strategy of ringing like grenades down
on people too good what do you guys
think I think ranae's strategies on
point I feel like so we did it so we're
doing well I think that was good that we
did that I think it was good we did that
come on guys it's the last game we could
do this
there's somebody damn it that's when I
hit somebody right it goes fifteen
[Music]
oh man this is great
whoo didn't hit the trap though I'm
killing people right to left now man
it's great jump ratchet it doesn't take
any skill you just fire these tennis
balls up in the air and it kills it me
yeah that's great escort dat payload oh
we're dead pelo oh that's a big
explosion let's get his paddle at night
oh but I kill awkward child and doing it
taking you with me awkward child
thank you Ray to 290 I appreciate that
playing pretty well for being a newbie
it's quiet there we go let's send my
little toy as soon as I see somebody
ah damn it
Oh but it didn't count as using my thing
all right here we go oh wait I did kill
somebody though by accident I must have
shot one thing just as I was dying oh
you know what no what happens is I think
my body will retract this how many good
spawn down
[Music]
lean back
Nataly gotta get that lean back I get
that lean back damn it
I'm back start it up
yeah take that guy out
but he killed me we're back got it don't
care all right let's go let's go let's
go
got to get back in there man done up a
lot of time just with this paler hold my
own
Killzone
kill the left
he's shot under the thing that's not
cool
damn it get up
I don't care about the kill kit where
the guys got a guitar or what's going on
guys come on man we got to do this we
were doing so well and now we've really
and we're doing much better
[Applause]
holy bring the car into battle Oh
[Music]
oh that was a good shot sparked on line
three that was a good shot
nice word and the guitar guy who's got a
guitar dude they play you a death so
yeah I know
let's go Antonio Banderas oh yeah oh
dude help me right you know what that's
good
oh that's really bad you got to kill
that turret and the thing guys we got to
kill that turret Oh f is that dude
healthy mushroom glories that's Spartan
[Music]
replacement overtime I know it is come
on guys last game we got to beat him
we're almost there
guitar guys kill it though man
whoops spoke too soon there we go over
time let's get in there let's get in
there no overtimes over we lost that's
it she lost damn
ah hey kiddo 1738 hey Dobbs that's a
great-looking junk rat right there how
do I live like that Wow the Ripper
I had a pride a couple pretty good
rivers let's be fair
oh yeah you know what forgetting killing
me so many times I'm giving it to soar
online notice though epic guys this is
awesome thank you so much for joining us
for stream calcio this week be a good
time thank you for playing with us we'll
see you guys next Monday at noon watch
the show tonight
Aubrey Plaza Frank Grillo we love Frank
Grillo and pierce the veil are on this
evening I check out our backlot movie
series becloud music series back a lot
music series where we film a band on a
location on the lot where movies have
been made that's pretty awesome and
don't forget to add me Blair as a
gamertag both on PlayStation and Xbox
you can play with us next time and for
Jason O'Malley Petrosky this is pen
stream kako see you guys don't forget to
subscribe to us on YouTube and twitch
and follow us you guys next week see you
later bye overwatch forever
you